police surrounded monsignor rolando
alvarez's parish to stop him from
celebrating mass at the nearby cathedral
the bishop of matagalpa is the latest
catholic leader to come under attack by
nicaragua's government
see yourself who are the ones who are
agitating the faithful the people of god
police patrols and agents versus
ordinary god-loving people respect us
please our lives our freedom and our
faith
monsignor alvarez has been an outspoken
critic of the government
30 kilometers away in cebaco another
priest father uriel vallejos had been
holed up in his parish for four days
surrounded by riot police without food
medicine or electricity
this incident follows a raid by
authorities who broke into the parish to
confiscate equipment belonging to the
church's radio station one of seven that
was ordered closed by the government on
monday
authorities say they did not apply for a
license to operate which the diocese
strongly denies
they're afraid we're denouncing
injustice they want to silence us
with the majority of government
opponents now in prison or in exile the
catholic church has become the main
voice of dissent against president
daniel ortega and his wife rosario
murillo who's also the vice president
the european union the international
human rights commission and the biden
administration have criticized the
attacks
the us under secretary for hemispheric
affairs brian nichols has tweeted
ortega murillo's brutal assault on
catholic clergy radio facilities and
community members in cebaco is another
blow to religious freedom in nicaragua
as well as the freedom of expression
in march the government expelled the
vatican's top diplomat and last month 18
nuns from mother teresa of calcutta's
order were also forced out
both moves were criticized by the
vatican but some priests and human
rights activists are calling on pope
francis to speak out himself on the
latest crackdown
the pope is maintaining an inexplicable
silence we don't understand what's
happening is he trying to dialogue
secretly with vice president morillo and
while he's silent it feels as if
nicaragua's catholic church has been cut
off by the pope right now
so far the pope has not commented
upon seeing these images vice president
murillo repeated charges that some
priests are quote servants of the devil
and yankee invaders
neither she nor her husband the
president has offered any proof
lucia newman al jazeera